[Musique]
série milchior président du conseil
départemental a reçu ce mercredi 3 avril
à la villa du département 350 agents
récemment titulariser ou stagiaires is
est une étape essentielle dans la
carrière de ces fonctionnaires
territoriaux
parmi ces cinq mille personnes il ya des
personnes qui viennent d'arriver qui
sont stagiaires
il vient d'être titularisé et de quoi
marquer leur arrivée j'ai souhaité que
le réunissent ici à la villa du
département quoi poney un moment
d'échangé et de dialogue
nous formons une grande famille la
famille des agents des élus du
département et cette grande famille
départementale elle est au service des
familles réunionnaises
c'est comme cela que je conçois une
relation cette matinée d'échangés et de
partage a permis au président de
rappeler l'importance du dialogue social
de concertation sur l'organisation de
l'administration et la vie des agents
[Musique]